all right fair enough Lord King
PlayStation showcase what's your
thoughts predictions were yet
I love this fan base man this man base
is is y'all are some beautiful toxic
individuals
toxic individuals it'd be like King you
can next week we break it through
next week you know we're gonna have God
Hand and everything everything's gonna
be there yo I love you guys because
y'all walk away from every state of play
every showcase oh yeah next one though
your next one so they never satisfied
yeah next one yo goes to shishima gonna
be there once he said that the
PlayStation VR gonna show up be prepared
to be disappointed
that's never been presents this is gonna
mess up the show urination Nation Oh man
yo yo somebody gonna rain on your parade
they're telling you it's rain somebody's
doing something they telling you it's
raining yo
all right guys my expectation this is my
expectation as a gamer let's go because
you guys is weirdos that's your
expectation my expectation
um I want all economy stuff that they
was talking about this is an old
showcase
when it was out there snitching
oh this is what they were supposed to
talk about back when it was out there
snitching and writing they had to make
themselves look weak
not everybody know the deal going
through
another this is the reason why they're
going early
they had this this is January during the
February joint That was supposed to show
up
so they're like oh man that deal going
through once the EU fell they was like
ah yo next week we uh did you notice
once the news came out it was like next
week so this is the fetus showcase I had
it on Deck no it's not the fetus it's
the fact that this is gonna be a very
strong Showcase from from all of the
individuals that I I mess with
uh
this this is going to be a strong
showcase yeah and remember Sony doesn't
care to show you things that's going to
be here that's not coming out for years
right right they just want to keep you
stuck on your controller man sit down
play with this remake
um put a little bit of the square stuff
that we got going on over here we got
Spider-Man instead Hold This Hold Us
Down and then we see you uh two years
from now we got Wolverines at some time
and somewhere ever in the future and
that's what's gonna be I want all
economic stuff that he was talking about
okay Metal Gear I'm at the Silent Hill
and I'm at the Castlevania I want all
three of them uh I want to walk away
from I want all three of them exclusive
I don't care about uh the Kratos DLC
that these dudes is bantering in in the
background I don't care about that
um
maybe a new Ratchet and Clank side
mission joint that'd be nice that'll be
fun uh
maybe a new Sackboy Adventures for your
your PlayStation VR if VR is going to be
there please put some of your main IPS
in VR showing me confidence in the VR
product so I know for a fact that you
guys plan to keep this thing around take
something that you're willing to invest
in and invest in it right don't give me
no sidebar uh Horizon call it a wild and
and tell me oh you know uh she's here
aloe is here but she's not here you know
you controlling uh dinkus
[Laughter]
you and dinkus you will make binkers go
up the
mountains will have to all other stuff I
don't care for dinkus
right so you want the main character IP
if you're strong in something and you're
standing behind your product I don't
yell I'll hold the line and don't you
don't say yo don't put Halo here no put
Halo here put something in it man
show me your confidence so again I want
all those Konami stuff that y'all been
bragging about that y'all been talking
about and it's just me calling out you
PlayStation frauds because you do don't
really know what's going to be there
y'all just be spitballing throwing stuff
in the air oh we blood ball ain't gonna
show up it's gonna be uh 4K 60 frames
um we we also gonna have the new God of
War oh Wolverine gonna show up we're
gonna have full game trailer and
gameplay uh and it's gonna have VR
support
so they doing too much expectations
that's what you're saying and they all
walk away with the Saints I clown y'all
every time uh-huh you talking about
clown yeah you're gonna come out with a
Canoa tool or something like that
what did y'all do y'all had the Little
Indie little dudes that y'all's running
around yeah I thought that was gonna be
it for y'all it's gonna be a lot of
Indie stuff oh no some passion projects
and [__] say yeah we got an extra uh
paid for admission
we got a paid for a mission I don't know
that sounds like an Xbox flavor for me
you know what you know what's nice
they don't know how to drop a mic I have
not seen him drop a mic in a long time
it's in Kool-Aid all I'm saying two
years you haven't seen them drop
anything for two years that's nice
that's nice but when they come to play
they come to play Hey I don't have you
confident in anything I know all I know
um
putting you on the spotlight what's
their biggest announcement for them for
Sony
video come on see you Wilding that we
can't take him seriously
I will hoping Silent Hill I told you I
want those Konami IPS that we already
know that they paid for that they paid
for that that's not in-house
I don't care like I know yo since when
they own anything like this I want them
to do this I want them to do what they
do best Gateway stuff and block stuff
off and money yo get your money hack
games there's gonna be plenty of that
there's gonna be some exclusive yeah
sprinkle your cash around cause your
time is running out sprinkle it around
as soon as that ABK deal go out we ain't
gonna be talking about this stuff no
more so sprinkle your cash and Silent
Hill please give me Silent Hill too
remake some y'all a masters of the
Remake Go remix yourself
these dudes are hype or remix
not one of these dudes say it's gonna be
a new Castlevania game no we're gonna
remake the first
um it's not gonna be a new metal gear
game no we're gonna remake metal get
solid and it's not it's not it's not
Metal Gear Solid either this part is
three
we want to bloodborne
y'all keep remaking
keep playing the same experience and
talk about it's new to me though shut up
man you Platinum that get out of here
them trophies
you Platinum boys
[Music]
we're gonna give you breath of the wild
again
in in at higher resolution uh-huh a
little bit cleaned up you happy for that
yeah I'll take tears to the kingdom over
a remake of something I did already give
me something different this is what I'm
trying to say I don't care if you
re-skid it those are nice games that you
put on the side but let's get these new
experiences out let's the house of Sony
the house of ideas
obviously the people that had ideas are
gone
I mean the only idea you got is let's
remake the AAA I agree with that right
like and we is it and this comes from
the PS1 era love and I I completely
agree with that like there's Tony back
and PS2 as well yeah PS3 is this this
PS4 weirdo dudes
got this strange energy around their
chest
strange energy Spirit bombs How You
Gonna remix the spirit boy we're gonna
send you the remix
my thing is I get mad at Xbox for not
even they know we talk about Xboxes
but the reactions to what Sony does
right and this is like they know the
reaction they'll get to certain things
yeah
I mean it's clear that the the the the
the the customer has spoken yeah
sometimes I feel like they just it being
different for the sake of being
different and just well Xbox has shown
that they want to differentiate
themselves
they've said Phyllis based obvious we
don't want to be a better version of The
Blue Team and a better version than the
red team he's literally said that right
but at the same time he's like making
everything there is there is something
to be said for yo King they remaking
their best hits from PS4
this is the reason why they get played
once in a while this is why for you for
you but see the Trophy Hunters uh
we already established that these dudes
don't have jobs
what are you guys
and he played these games
where where is these where's these stats
that you're speaking I don't know go ask
one of those dudes who carries
we've established anyway go act the
Remake Posse
I better they better not come with
another remake next week if they remake
The Last of Us Again with Pedro that's
our face
it'd be like and for that new HBO Max
fail
Yo's face y'all can go get that right
now for 79.50
anyway I think it's my turn
yeah Bessie is oh my God you're
ridiculous
um yeah look oh I want to shout out dual
shocking says podcast module with a team
I was on there um yesterday
and they was talking they were doing
that prediction show too and um to me I
think one would think Last of Us
factions has to be a lock at this point
like we would need to see what's going
on with that game with multiplayer joint
see what's up Spider-Man 2 the question
I have will they have the release date
or will they wait until maybe like
another like stated play as it gets
closer supposed to be in September yeah
but did they announce did they
officially I don't think they officially
announced no I I heard rumors is like
the seventh or something like that yeah
when it start when is Starfield the
Starfield is oh what is it
I'm blanking on Starfield state for
whatever the September I think they come
out like probably a week before star
would feel but we know it's the same
month we just gotta figure out the day
but I'm curious to see if obviously the
show more but if they um give the
release date then
um I think I agree with King though
psvr is going to be there psvr2 is going
to be there that it underperformed this
is like let's say the last chance but
this is they've got to make a strong
impression for those they make a a big
strong impression or just splashes them
it's okay so no no I'm sorry we will see
new games for sure I don't know how big
the impression's gonna be uh I mean
they've got this stuff like a quarter of
the show is VR
well I mean I don't know how I don't
okay
toxic dude you're Toxic Event I don't
know how long of a presence they wow but
they will have a presence because they
have to they got to get confidence in
this they got to get people confident in
that product because we saw the forecast
they did not reach those forecasts it
underperformed and this is like you know
a last shot to get people so I'm gonna
solve like if you could get like a a
half Half-Life Alex like if you had to
bet your life
would you would you
just on guarding them like if they say
you're listening man
you gotta bet your life if Half-Life
Alex gonna be there would you say yes or
no no I'm not fair by life I bet my life
that PS VR games are going to be there
no no psvr games is gonna be there I'm
talking about that triple A Half-Life
Alex they need it they need it do you
think it would be there
I'm not betting my life but I'm like
it's a good chance they try look they
got beat saved which is a big game in VR
like that regardless people like that is
a huge deal is fantastic right so the
next thing is you need that
transformative experience to say okay
this is what you can do that you really
can't do anywhere else and we have it on
our platform and then like you said show
the new IPS that kind of have their
tried and true you know peanut butter
and jelly names you know like we said he
didn't have the alloy this time I mean
we had things but
but you need to have something with I
don't know sky in it or something you
know you need something with something
with your big names you know what I'm
saying Uncharted you know somebody got
to be in VR to make people go okay let
me go rock out this is a different you
know bespoke experience with this
classic IP Legacy on it you think this
passion project is going to take that
deep of a um a risk I mean they don't
what choice do they have at this point
the product is not salad and it's
totally fizzle out and go away they
literally themselves on the blog post
said look out for psvr2 titles on this
joint so I expect to be there so that's
that
um
[Laughter]
straight VR you're ridiculous
um I do think we're gonna get Hardware I
think we're gonna get Hardware this show
I think we're gonna get you know I agree
with Tom Henderson I think we're gonna
get we're not I don't think we're gonna
get the pro but I think we'll get the
slim maybe we get the slim do you think
we get that uh the handout yes that one
I'm pretty confident that one yeah yeah
so you get the Q like the the remote
joint you know the remote play the show
is a little companion thing now to Ken's
credit
where they could get in trouble if they
spend too much time on hardware and they
spend too much time on VR that could
lose the audience and and to be honest
with you the way you're talking like it
might seem like that might happen you
got that VR you got this this slim this
handheld like they might it's only an
hour right so it to me
the pacing is gonna be kicked but all of
that's not gonna matter if they show
that AAA Banger that we didn't know
about or some big IP that is exclusive
and you go oh my God because you know
what's gonna happen so it's gonna be
some we're gonna go oh what's that and
then we wait for the end and you're
gonna see it and say only on place
and you don't see nothing else now the
king go pop bottles if it'll say nothing
at the end and then they go to Twitter
and people go yeah yeah guys it's on
it's on Xbox two that's what kid gonna
do to try to I'm gonna try to minimize
anything they doing but that's going to
be the key what big third party
exclusive whether it be Silent Hill 2
Metal Gear Solid three that if they
could snap something that takes the soul
that's going to hurt if people gonna go
oh oh God we could we could only do it
over there
that's and that's what they technically
that show gonna be a six out of ten yeah
I know you coming I know which position
you're coming
so yeah that's what I got little
machenko face
to walk this back I'm not walking
anything back I'm going into this
because they drop a spirit ball they're
gonna be ordered that was so dope about
me
when I'm right there I will say this if
you write about this show being garbage
when I'm right
you guys can't stop me and I'm telling
you now this show gonna be a six out of
ten for that PSV so you telling me for
two years they wait for two years it's
gonna be a garbage show they ain't gonna
be nothing fired
hold up you know what we're gonna do you
know what we're gonna do we're gonna
make this interesting
I'm gonna get Jada to do the reaction I
want him here so bad yo I I want him to
hear so bad like you realize
I want as much PlayStation dudes here so
bad I want you dudes here so I want
y'all to be enforced I want y'all to be
having your hands in the air pumping
your chest and as I said sit there
laughing at your showcase and deflating
you and telling you this is exact I told
you what was gonna happen to you but you
did listen yeah
we'll see what happens